bonjour à tous merci beaucoup pour
l'accueil l'introduction merci aussi à
romain qui a bien introduit le sujet que
je vous présenter tout de suite donc
arretez de ghost et vous utilisateurs
ghost et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
servir bien entendu de l'anglais ghost
fantôme est donc là on va parler de quoi
parler de nos utilisateurs finaux dans
un processus de création
donc qu'est-ce que c'est le phénomène du
ghost d'un utilisateur c'est finalement
quand vous allez dans une relation
amicale ou amoureuse
il y aurait quelqu'un vous allez arrêter
de lui répondre parce que peut-être que
il a dit quelque chose qui vous a pas
plu ou vous pensez que finalement il ya
quelque chose qui qui passent plus il
n'ya plus le feeling ou en tout cas plus
grand chose à se dire je pense que on a
tous été consciemment ou inconsciemment
dans la situation du goaster ou du ghost
et et je pense aussi qu'il ya un beau
parallèle à faire avec le processus de
création de projets de d'une maison
d'une aire de jeux d'un service ou d'un
objet du quotidien
j'avais oublié d'appuyer sur ce bouton
pardon donc premier premier cas d' usage
on voit cette zone de cette zone urbaine
qui a été aménagé par un architecte un
urbaniste et donc qu'est ce qu'il a fait
mais il a fait des choses bien
géométriques bien car eh bien comme lui
avais envie de le faire sauf qu'il a
complètement ghost et ses utilisateurs
puisqu'il s'est focalisé sur le besoin
fonctionnel un passage pour aller au
travail ou à la maison
mais il n'a pas pris en compte le besoin
utilisateur qui était d'aller vite
d'aller rapidement
pourquoi parce que le bus peut être en
retard parce que les gens aiment se
lever tard pour aller au travail
moi le premier
et du coup bah on peut imaginer que si
demain il y avait un réaménagement de
cette zone là la mairie ou en tout cas
la ville où les urbanistes prendrait en
compte ce petit détail ce petit chemin
qui a été creusée qui a été marquée par
les utilisateurs finaux pour réaménager
le l'urbanisme de cette place et pour
faciliter les flux des utilisateurs
si on va un petit peu plus loin henri
heinz dans les années 1870 s'est inventé
le conditionnement du ketchup pour le
grand public
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'il ya une petite bouteille dans
lequel on va mettre le ketchup et là
pendant cent vingt ans heinz a
complètement ghost et ses utilisateurs
alors pas que de par sa faute mais aussi
de par les innovations technologiques
qui n'étaient pas là mais en gros on a
tous été confrontés à la petite goutte
de ketchup qui reste au fond et c'est
juste ce qui nous manque pour terminer
ses frites et donc forcément va on le
secoue dans tous les sens on dormait
partout et puis au final on n'arrive pas
à finir seyfried dont qu'ils ont inventé
ça il ya à peu près 30 ans maintenant 35
ans est donc là ils ont ils sont rentrés
dans un processus finalement demain on a
essayé de répondre à un besoin
utilisateur est plus un besoin
j'irai de de packaging ou de production
de productivité dernier petit exemple
que je vous montre des des best-of of
ghosting google donc en 2005 il avait
déjà plus de 150 mille utilisateurs par
jour unique
et ils ont sorti cette interface à
gauche alors on pourrait se dire bon
qu'est-ce que c'est en même temps ça
fait écho à apple qui revenait assez
fort dans la dans le marché de
l'ordinateur et apple avait son dock je
sais pas si vous voulez de quoi je parle
mais en gros c'est l'endroit où toutes
les applications natives de osx sont
mises en exergue et où on peut cliquer
pour accéder directement une application
donc là google s'est dit bah tiens ça
marche super bien sûr les nouveaux mac
on va essayer de faire la même chose sur
notre moteur de recherche et du coup ils
ont voulu aider l'utilisateur à filtrer
sa recherche
en ajoutant ces petits pictogrammes donc
le pictogramme images qui nous
permettait d'aller directement
rechercher une image etc etc
sauf qu'en fait au bout d'une journée
ils se sont aperçus que les gens ne
l'utilisait pas du tout que pour le plus
simple c'est est de taper directement
dans le moteur de recherche
ce dont il avait besoin et que dans tous
les cas ça marchait donc au bout d'une
journée ils l'ont carrément enlevé et
ils sont revenus sur interface plus
classique alors ça c'est pas l'interface
de 2005 après la mise à jour c'est
l'interface dire mais c'est celle qu'on
connaît c'est celle qu'ils ont gardé
beaucoup plus épuré pure est beaucoup
plus simple et qui répondent aux besoins
utilisateurs de rechercher et trouver
malheureusement dans ma petite
expérience j'ai je suis tombé sur des
gens c'étaient des gosses turfoo ils ont
ils ont pas du tout conscience de la
mine d'or que leurs utilisateurs
pourraient leur apporter pour développer
leurs produits et du coup je vous ai
réunis les trois punchline qui m'ont
vraiment marqué pendant ces sept petites
années professionnelles
donc on a fait une étude quantique ali
c'est tout bon on maîtrise tous les
tenants et aboutissants de nos clients
et de nos usagers donc ça c'est une
directrice marketing qui m'a dit ça un
commercial d'un grand groupe qui m'a dit
non mais mes clients je les connais par
coeur on va pas perdre de temps elle est
allée connaître mieux en savoir plus
pas la peine je maîtrise tout est enfin
un pdg d'entreprises qui m'a dit mais
pourquoi vous voulez analyser les
besoins de
clients on sait déjà ce qu'on va mettre
sur le site sur notre application
pas besoin de savoir ce dont ils ont
envie donc ça ouais pour moi c était
vraiment assez marquant mais
heureusement à côté de ça j'ai eu
d'autres clients qui eux étaient
beaucoup plus intéressés beaucoup plus
soucieux de l'expérience qu'ils allaient
donner à leurs clients et du coup je
vais vous parler d'une application
mobile que j'ai créé bien entendu pas
tout seul mais pour les chauffeurs poids
lourds
donc la première chose qu'on a fait
c'est directement allé les voir parce
qu'en fait finalement ces jours là moi
ils sont vraiment très éloigné de mon
milieu j'ai jamais eu personne dans ma
famille ou dans mon cercle proche qui
faisait cette activité là donc la
première chose que je suis allé faire
face et essayer de trouver des gens qui
pouvaient me faire monter dans un camion
et qui pouvait me faire vivre leur vie
finalement donc j'ai rencontré plein de
gens je pourrais vous citer fil 26
arthur 6,9
isabelle qui est responsable d'une
association enfin voilà bref mais tout
ça pour dire que j'ai essayé de me
ménager au plus au plus profond de ce
qu'ils vivent au quotidien pour être sûr
de bien comprendre leur tenant les
aboutissants et répondre à leurs besoins
dans notre application
je suis même allé dans des restos
routiers ou finalement je suis allé
casser la graine avec eux comme ils
disent
le boire une bière à l'après le boulot
et discuter un petit peu de tous les
problèmes qui peuvent avoir dans leur
quotidien et c'est là que je me suis
rendu compte que finalement c'était un
boulot très compliqué avec beaucoup de
contraintes légales mais aussi
personnelles légal parce que par exemple
pour une journée de travail de huit
heures un chauffeur doit s'arrêter au
minimum toutes les quatre heures pour
faire une pause légal de 45 minutes
s'ils le font pas et peuvent se faire
arrêter on peut leur prendre leur permis
de conduire etc
donc ça peut avoir vraiment des impacts
importants mais ils ont aussi d'autres
contraintes
en fonction de ce qu'ils vont
transporter typiquement si on transporte
des produits nucléaires on n'a pas le
droit de passer à côté d'un fleuve par
exemple ou si on transporte quelque
chose de très grand et ça il va falloir
qu'on évite tous les ponts et tous les
tunnels du trajet pour être sûr
d'arriver
à bon port il ya d'autres petites
contraintes
je suis aussi allé sur des aires
d'autoroutes et j'ai essayé de parler
avec des personnes qui étaient
originaires d'autres pays la plupart du
temps de l'europe de l'est et donc leurs
contraintes c'était de partir longtemps
loin de leur famille typiquement une
personne pouvait partir jusqu'à trois
semaines quatre semaines donc seul dans
sa cabine avec ses raviolis et son
réchaud et sa petite télé donc vraiment
dans un dans un contexte assez précaire
est assez rudimentaire donc que ben
voilà ils ont zéro contact avec leur
famille avec leurs amis donc on a essayé
de répondre à ces besoins là à chaque
fois qu'on a rencontré des gens on a
essayé de garder le contact avec eux
donc l'objectif c'est qu'on puisse les
contacter et échanger sur le long terme
avec eux donc le jour où on a mis en
place la première version de
l'application qu'on avait créé vous
qu'après quelques mois d'immersion au
plus profond de ce milieu on a pu du
coup proposer aux gens de télécharger
l'application et de nous envoyer des
retours donc aussi bien des feedbacks et
technique que bat aussi des suggestions
d'améliorations qui ont dû nous dire bah
oui effectivement moi il me manquerait
samoa il manquerait ça là vous n'avez
pas pu me la possibilité d'avoir telle
option et ce serait intéressant de
l'avoir etc
je sais pas si vous connaissez ça la
cibi alors c'est un peu old school et ça
n'existe plus mais mais en gros c'est
les grandes antennes qu'on voyait sur
les camions et sur les voitures
donc en fait c'était hyper important
pour eux de la voir et c'est une des
fonctionnalités qu'on a essayé de
remettre dans notre application nom
typiquement il utilisait du coup pour se
parler ça c'est un outil de
communication donc sur les ondes radio
et donc on la refait dans l'app et on
s'en est servi aussi pour récupérer des
feedbacks utilisateurs donc typiquement
bas donc fil 26 par exemple prenez
l'application il nous disait elle il ya
le truc marche plus
et du coup nous on pouvait lui répondre
en instantané oui ok on a bien pris en
compte et on va essayer de résoudre le
problème
pour aller jusqu'au bout de cette
passion et de
enfin pour en tout cas pour essayer de
la comprendre on a aussi été aux 24
heures du mans poids lourds donc je
savais pas qu'il y avait ça mais en fait
c'est hyper intéressant de ce qu'on a vu
des donc les camions vous voyez à gauche
faire la course à plus de 160 km heure
en faisant un vacarme énorme et ben
voila c'était assez marrant tu pars
c'est partager ça avec eux parce que
c'est un peu leur rendez vous annuel
voilà c'était vraiment un projet humain
où on a rencontré des gens qui ne sont
pas du tout à l'image de ce qu'on a en
tête du chauffeur poids lourds convois
sur une aire d'autoroute avec un marcel
et sa tâche de gradés bolognaise 2010 je
fais exprès de tirer un trait un peu
parce que c'est pas du tout ça en vrai
c'est ça qui était vraiment beau dans le
projet et est du coup en étant au plus
près d'eux on a réussi à bien comprendre
leurs besoins et a aussi adapté
l'application en fonction autre exemple
de non ghosting de d'utilisateurs finaux
un client est venu me voir un jour et il
m'a dit ah ben voilà aujourd'hui mon
site internet il convertit plus assez
j'ai vraiment besoin qu'on leur fasse en
sorte de plus vendre donc on a analysé
un petit peu le besoin on a analysé un
petit peu le site
et là on s'est aperçu que effectivement
le problème venait du tunnel d'achat
alors qu'est ce que le tunnel d'achat
tunnel d'achat c'est le moment entre le
panier et la commande le moment où vous
saisissez vos informations de carte
bancaire et que vous payez donc la
création de contes l'adresse de
livraison la saisie de l'adresse de
facturation le paiement on est allé dans
des magasins et on a essayé de regarder
enfin de demander à des gens
d'utiliser le site pour voir où étaient
les points de blocage donc directement
dans les magasins les gens étaient sur
leur dit et il nous montrait bah oui ben
là finalement je me souviens plus de ce
que j'ai mis au panier ou là je vois pas
bien où est le bouton d'action où avais
je me souviens plus le prix mais j'avais
pas une réduction sur cet article là
donc voilà on a essayé de comprendre
tous les points de blocage et une fois
qu'on a bien compris tout ça on leur a
proposé donc une interface sas et un
croquis wire fremm comme on appelle ça
une interface où on essayait de résoudre
un petit peu tous les problèmes donc on
l'a fait pour tous les écrans du tunnel
et on est allé après dans la rue le
proposer à des gens lambda alors il y en
a quelques-uns qui ont dit non non j'ai
pas le temps et puis je souscris déjà
mais un médecin du monde donc je
mais bon on a quand même insisté il y en
a quand même quelques-uns qui ont bien
voulu nous répondre
donc du coup on a essayé de voir si ce
qu'on avait proposé était quand même
intéressant et si ça répondait et ça ça
améliorerait l'expérience d'achat sur le
site qu'au final c'est plutôt pas trop
mal passé on a eu donc le client
analysait quelques quelques chiffres
clés donc c'est pas la peine forcément
de rentrer dans le détail mais en tout
cas ce qui a été vraiment valorisant
c'est que dès que le site a été mis à
jour avec les nouvelles interfaces les
ventes ont explosé et du coup tout le
monde était content aussi bien nous que
notre client final projet qui est encore
en cours qui est la traduction de la lsf
de la langue des signes
donc personnellement j'y connais pas
grand chose encore une fois sur ce sujet
j'essaye de me documenter vu qu'on est
en train de faire un projet là dessus
mais on aimerait donc monté un une
application qui va te permettre de
traduire la langue des signes en temps
réel donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que vous ou si un jour vous croisez une
personne qui ne parle pas le français
mais qui parlent la langue des signes
vous pourrez dialoguer avec elle grâce à
votre téléphone portable ou à votre
ordinateur il suffit juste d'avoir une
webcam de filmer les gestes par exemple
bonjour et derrière notre application
avoue transcrire vocalement ou
textuellement l'information que le votre
interlocuteur vous donnera donc la vue
qu'on n'y connaît rien du tout moi et
toute l'équipe qui travaille sur le
sujet on va directement contacté les
associations et les personnes qui sont
soit mal entendants de soit bilingue
soit carrément sourde pour finalement
mais l'application elle-même
donc nous ce qu'est ce qu'on va mettre
en place c'est la faculté de pouvoir
contribuer au projet le modèle
d'intelligence artificielle et de
machine learning qui va permettre de
reconnaître les signes et les traduire
en temps réel et ensuite c'est du coup
les personnes parlant la lsf qui vont
faire le projet pour les personnes qui
parlaient les s'est fait comme ça on est
sûr que le produit sera en adéquation
avec les attentes et que les
utilisateurs ne seront pas boosté alors
je sais pas si je vous ai convaincu sur
le gosse mais en tout cas on peut pas
nier qu'il y aura forcément des
évolutions de tous les produits on peut
pas faire bien du premier coup par
contre en allant au plus près des
utilisateurs je suis quasiment sûr que
votre produit sera toujours meilleur est
toujours de meilleure qualité et
répondra toujours mieux à vos
utilisateurs
pour conclure je dirais que un bon
produit un bon un bon service ou en tout
cas peu importe que vous ce que vous
allez créer par la suite mais je pense
que c'est un peu comme une relation
d'amitié avec votre meilleure amie si
vous n'allez pas le voir régulièrement
si vous n'allez pas l'appeler
régulièrement vous allez passer à côté
de plein de choses
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]